this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about
your life your money your work
your relationships we're talking life it
all plays together
i am ken coleman joined by my colleague
john deloney
and we are taking you through this hour
of the ramsay show triple eight eight
two five five two two five
is the phone number it's a free call
triple eight eight two five
five two two five and john we've got a
full lobby here at ramsey solutions
some fantastic people out there we've
got some debt free screams coming up
we got a teacher interview coming up we
got people calling to get
clarity coming up and uh it's always fun
to be with you my friend thanks man you
too looking forward to it it's good to
see everyone out there
yeah yeah great great group by the way
great reminder we are open
if you want to come to nashville and uh
the area and come a little south here in
franklin
uh check us out ramseysolutions.com let
us know you're coming we've got
uh free baked goods coffee you got your
iced coffees you got your
i don't know do they have any juice over
there yes they got the juice yes they
got it
yeah i got the juice do you well that's
because i'm passionate about what i do
that's what we say on the ken coleman
show when you're living on purpose and
working on purpose
you got the juice i see in the it's not
just a j-o-b john in the health and
wellness industry the juice
steroids so it's cool man well i think
anybody that's watching on youtube right
now can take a quick gander at me
and quickly certainly you look pretty
dad i'm not on that kind of
juice yeah disagree you know i mean i
don't think i'm gonna shock anybody with
that statement
if you hang on till hour three today
good folks ken and i are going to do
push-ups push-ups that's right you know
this desk is big enough for me to get on
that end and i
i'm short and i don't think hits you if
we go head-to-head
uh during the commercial break maybe
we'll get that kelly's not sure kelly's
long enough but my self-esteem is not
quite that long
it's it's yeah i couldn't do it i could
do that
could you yeah i have no problem
knocking out some push-ups all right but
we're not gonna say that for the next
segment all right triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're gonna have
a blast today you know why
because we're going to be diving in with
you whether it's talking about your
relationships
toxicity at work hey am i doing what i
love how do i make more money what do i
do with my budget how do i get out of
debt
this is all going somewhere that really
really matters and that's why this is
going to be fun let's go to tallahassee
florida to start it off
chris joins us there chris you're on the
ramsay show
hey guys how's it going appreciate you
having me we're having a blast what's up
hey um quick question for you guys so
i'm you know going through baby steps
and we're
on the ladder into that um so i've got a
structure to set on my
payment coming up um this february and
uh it's got 50 000 coming in
and looking to see if i need to just
send that you know max out the
roth ira that that year and then put the
rest and i got a son
um put into his 529 kind of max that out
and then put the rest towards the house
or how would you guys kind of split that
up
sounds like you're following the baby
steps is that true
yep so one well baby step are you ready
uh so this is going into four and five
kind of a hybrid there okay um so
we've got about with an employer match
got about 12
going into the retirement um so
what's the settlement from um so i had a
motorcycle accident um
about 10 years ago now um so we got a
payment this february and then i got a
couple others
um in five year batches out until i'm
until i'm 40.
okay yeah well i mean you know the baby
steps and so
you know i think your question is spot
on but that's what you do you you allow
you
you take this settlement and you plug it
into the baby steps
okay yeah would you suggest going more
so
more towards the house early on and kind
of just
the 529 is rolling um and will be you
know
primed up and paid up by the time i send
goes to college
would you suggest putting more towards
the house
how much well let's play the numbers how
much do you mind telling us how much the
settlement is
it's 50 000. 50 000 coming on this wave
and i got 100 000
on the ladder too okay so 150 total
correct or no 250. oh okay all right all
right so 250.
so how much uh would you need to put
into the 529
i understand it's rolling um and so but
what's the difference right now like how
much of that would get him to
that number that you want for the
college fund
so it's probably going to be about 45
we'll just pay it up
and kind of get that flat baseline and
then obviously the quicker you get it
paid up you know it can
accrue you know tax-free interest yeah
um how much do you own your house
uh 128 on it right now yeah i
i would finish out the college fund uh
because that's going to accrue now
you've knocked that step
out completely and so the money you were
putting into that now we start putting
that towards the house and then the rest
of the money that
just so it's the same idea as the
debt-free snowball here
and so you just take that money finish
out the college fund step that's there
now it's fully funded it's going and now
we re
we take those funds and we knock out as
much of the house as you can it
with the understanding that no matter
what your employment status is in five
years you're gonna get a hundred
thousand dollar check
and it's correct and that's you know the
idea with all these steps is obviously
to avoid
having any any type of fallback or
anything like that well yeah but by the
you you really are running as fast as
you can towards paying your house off
yeah
knowing that regardless of where you are
in five years that's going to be what
pays your house off
right so i would front load those yeah
front load your accounts on the front
end here yeah because you've got a five
year you're going to be completely debt
free
completely paid up on your on your uh
5.9 you're going to be where you need to
be in five years regardless yeah um
so man yeah the earlier you can get that
stuff accruing interest yeah so just
knock it the answer is
knock out four and five yeah so knock
them out and follow him
and you're gonna be fine you you don't
need you you've got a backup plan i mean
just think about that just the money
he's gonna put in his house if you feel
a hard time you sell the house
there's so much equity in it and then
you're debt-free on six anyway
so yeah just follow it out don't
overthink it and i think
to speak to that what's the what's the
psychology there for a guy who again
he's just like me he's just like
everybody else he's walking this stuff
out he's in great financial shape this
settlement is only going to make it
better but yet there's still fear should
i spend this money
we struggle so much with just how s
little we control in the world yeah how
simple life is when we just
play it out right when we if we can just
put our head in
the mind of the tortoise and just take
little steps one after the other and so
yeah it's fifty thousand dollars come on
just follow the plan man and it feels
like we're not doing enough it feels
like well i gotta be doing more and this
is a bit
just keep following that plan and can i
can't tell you how many times i've tried
to
short-circuit it hey i'll just do double
the workouts today
yeah and that'll get me double the in
shape tomorrow it just makes me so sore
you can't move right yeah
so i'm i'm not the licensed psychologist
i don't have the training you do but
when i'm talking to people like this on
the ken coleman show and we get a
question like this
i'm going to go okay let's just lay this
out what's the fear
name the thing you're afraid of well i
lose my job can i
i think that's important would you agree
with that so it's really you know i'm
not going to make chris do that because
chris is in great shape but it's almost
like chris
and if anybody's like chris what are you
really scared of
what's the name the way i say it is
write it down i love it and then
demand evidence from it yeah are you
seriously yeah the worst mom oh
yeah put it on the witness stand yep
you're not
right are you really too overweight for
someone to love you no you're not i
love you are you seriously gonna be
broke in five years
by falling baby steps yeah no you're not
yeah most of the time if you demand
evidence from your fears
you realize you've been lying to
yourself right right
and then accept the truth and focus on
the truth
hey i got this we're gonna do this take
a deep breath
and keep on moving let me tell you what
we're going to do we're going to keep on
broadcasting
life-changing radio don't move this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
welcome back america you have joined the
conversation here on the ramsey show i'm
ken coleman joined with my colleague
john daloni and we're taking your
questions about your life
your work your relationships and
we are here for you i just feel like
somebody needs to call today you're
going i've thought about it before
i think today's the day well let's go
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five
two two five well it's april john and
you know around here that's a big big
month for ramsey solutions because
it's national financial literacy month
and with all of our involvement with
ramsey ed
ramsey education solutions in america
schools
we do our teacher appreciation giveaway
it's sponsored by mint mobile
the affordable premium wireless provider
and because of the dedicated teachers
across the country our foundations in
personal finance curriculum
is teaching students how to save avoid
debt and pay cash for things like cars
and college
it's changing family trees helping kids
not maybe make the mistakes that their
parents and grandparents made
and we love these testimonies so
teachers
anybody listening if you are a teacher
we want you to enter today for a chance
to win some awesome prizes like
5 000 in cash
you can use that however you like go to
ramseysolutions.com
teacher that's ramsay solutions dot com
slash teacher and you've got to enter by
april the 30th if you're not a teacher
share this
with a teacher in your life and one of
the things we love to do
here on the ramsay show is highlight
the unbelievable impact that the
teachers who engage with us
and teach foundations and personal
finance in their school
and the impact they make and so we are
going to go to
amanda who joins us on the line she is
at temple high school
in the atlanta georgia area amanda
you're on the ramsay show
hi guys thanks for talking with me
what's up you bet hey where is
where whereabouts in the atlanta area's
temple high school
well we're not really in atlanta it's
temple georgia but we're really close
we're about
if you go i-20 west we're about 40
minutes outside oh yeah yeah yeah sure
sure i got you
all right very good and uh this is a
public school i'm looking here with 627
kids enrolled and you've been a teacher
for how many years
this is my 14th year wow and how long
have you been teaching foundations
in personal finance eight wow
so how did you come across dave ramsey
or our curriculum yeah so i'm kind of a
lifer i'm kind of a fan girl for dave um
and john it's good to talk to you
because i had the pleasure of talking
with you last week on your show it
hasn't aired yet but i'm excited to hear
that back
yeah it's great to talk to you i first
uh went through spu as a college kid and
then
my husband and i took it again in fact
we missed our very first week of class
on our honeymoon
so like the second we got married we
went through it again
and i've led nine fpu classes i think
now to the church
and it's just so exciting to bring this
content to the high school kids
so fun so when you first brought it to
the school what was that like getting it
started take us to the early days
eight years ago of beginning this
process of teaching this
yeah well i kind of get to start over
again this is my first year at
temple so i brought it with me when i
came over and it's been
so exciting to share this with these
kids because we had financial literacy
here but it wasn't the ramsey content
and just
the the content just makes it so
relatable
and easy to grasp ideas
that are so counter cultural to what
they're being told
you know i've had tons of parents react
in lots of different ways some are
excited and they're emailing me saying
hey send me your tax information stuff
because i'm about to do my taxes and and
i want to make sure i'm doing a ride or
or you know send me the chapter you
taught on budgeting like can i talk
about that
but then i've also had parents at a
previous system that said
i don't know what you're teaching my kid
but i don't want them to be in your cult
you know i mean it's kind of you know
it's very
different you know having to to approach
the kids with
with these ideas and knowing that
they're so different than what they're
hearing at home
yeah that's fantastic so hey pain is
paint us a picture of the last year or
two
for the average teacher
um there was a forced giggle if i've
ever heard one
utter chaos to be honest um i i have
several
friends that have left the industry um
and and i have several that you know
myself included where i feel like
i'm in my sweet spot even more now than
i was before
you know to use ken's language so um
it's it's weird it's it's hard it's
challenging
we have i teach business and financial
so
you know there are things that covet has
affected positively
for our young people uh as far as the
way they approach the workforce the
the the doors that are now open with you
know virtual working and working from
home and this
is not that i i kind of have a new
curriculum to teach
you know how to do business and finance
in this new world you know when the
banks are closed well how do you do
online banking you know things like that
so
um it's it's challenging but it's forced
us to be creative
sounds like you are a teacher who's been
in the business that
i used to teach as well at a public high
school and man after one year it's easy
just to say okay i've already got that
lesson done and i'm gonna i'm gonna
coast
and it sounds like you are a teacher
who's so invested in the
changed outcomes for your in your
students lives that you are somebody
who's
constantly revising constantly trying to
find new things constantly challenging
yourself
and it's exhausting and frustrating and
annoying but it's the
it's the rich part of the gig too
absolutely
for sure i'm so glad you make me happy
that my kids are
in the community in a public school
because there's teachers like you
millions of you everywhere across the
country doing extraordinary works i'm so
grateful for you you are joining our
conversation with
amanda wilson who is a teacher at temple
high school in temple georgia
and she teaches our foundations in
personal finance curriculum
and we are honoring her for uh financial
literacy month
and amanda i want to ask you take us uh
to a story that pops up
top of your heart uh about a kid or
maybe multiple kids
that got this stuff and and did
something
really cool with it or they you saw the
change really stick and as a result
some great results yeah well this is the
first year i've been with this group of
students so
the longevity stories i don't really
have a lot of those but what i am
starting to see because i'm still in the
same community as the school i came from
is that now i've kind of started a side
hustle ministry on i mean i'm not
charging for it but
my previous financial babies would come
back and they're like
okay i just graduated nursing school and
i got a 35 000
bonus what do i do now you know and so
they'll call me and say
hey can i get you coffee can we talk
about my budget or can i
how do i do this and so it's kind of
started a little ministry counseling
thing once a student always a student
and so they know that there's always a
safe place for them to come back and ask
questions and
and get advice and things like that and
and that's what's
so powerful is that i'm i'm teaching
this to adults i'm living this in my
family we're on baby step
six um in fact yesterday my husband and
i paid cash for our dave car
new car um tell us about that
what kind of car come on we gotta brag a
little bit you earned it
well it's modest it's a 2017 ford
explorer but
it's got all the bells and so many
whistles
wrote a check and walked off the lot it
was so good fantastic
boy it drives better oh my gosh
i didn't know how bad my own car was i
thought it was okay until i got in a new
one
you know what here's the thing though it
was okay
you made it work that's what i want
people to hear you made it work
uh and it is okay and yet now you're in
a place where you earned it amanda let
me just say on behalf of john and
our entire uh ramsey solutions team
we're proud to be associated with men
and women like you
who are giving of yourself beyond the
classroom you are truly
leaving a legacy so thank you for
joining us on the call
thank you for what you do well it's my
pleasure and thank you for all the great
content i look forward to seeing you
guys at summit virtually
hey come on all right that's going to be
a lot of fun
well john i mean that's what it's about
yeah let's not forget
that we did some study here at ramsey
solutions
and the third largest group of net worth
millionaires in the united states
our teacher and after having been a
teacher and my wife's been a teacher for
years
they don't make billionaire money they
make millionaire decisions
great every single day great statement
love that all right
john deloney ken coleman here with you
on the ramsey show
don't move because i'm looking out the
lobby and i see ourselves
a great couple who's gonna be doing a
debt-free screen don't move we're coming
right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show america
thrilled to have you with us as we talk
about your life
your work money relationships
and how to live to the fullest live like
no one else so that you can give like no
one else
dr john deloney joins me i'm ken coleman
we're ramsey's
uh ramsay personalities we both have our
own shows the ken coleman show and the
dr john daloni show on
the ramsey network and we're taking you
through this
hour in the lobby of ramsey solutions
world headquarters are jacob and heather
welcome
hello ken hey dr john what's up where
are you guys from
st louis missouri all right all right
and uh you're here because
you're dead for debt-free that's fun so
let's learn how much you paid off tell
us the number
we paid off a hundred and fifty five
thousand and nine hundred dollars
wow and how long did it take you to do
that four years and one month four years
in one month
so you'll ground i love the specificity
always of these stories hey when you go
five years it is just every month counts
that's exactly what it is
and uh range of income um so we started
around a hundred thousand um and then
we're at about a hundred and twenty five
thousand now oh nice what'd you do to
bump it up
uh job changes yeah and a lot of
overtime yeah
what do you both do i'm a nurse and i'm
a letter carrier for the post office
nice so you you were racking some
overtime as well for the usps
yes i was okay how crazy was it during
uh during the coven
um parcel wise it was really crazy but
other than that it wasn't other than
that all right good now what type of
debt are we talking about
we paid off our mortgage
that was the only debt you had it was
the only time we had wow
okay so what happened uh so here we go
let's see four years one month ago
you guys go on this journey how did this
come about um
we bought a we got married and what
every married couple does is
they go and buy a house it was an
impulse buy it was the first thing i've
ever impulse bought and i immediately
felt terrible
it was a house um wow i imposed by like
dorito tacos not at home that's really
impressive
yeah so we knew that we needed to get
things together
and how long you been married four years
yeah
okay so you got married bought a house
and then looked at each other and went
oh no
wow so were you familiar with dave
ramsey ramsey solutions i mean
where did this guilt come from within
moments of walking inside the home
um so when i was little my aunt had a
total money makeover book in her house
but i don't they never really
followed so i kind of knew the name but
other than that
he started listening right after we
bought the house actually and
he started talking to me about the
principles which made sense
um i was always raised if you don't have
cash you don't buy it
and so i mean to us that made sense and
you were already there
yourself you were like i don't like this
155 000 okay yeah
interesting so what was the decision
like
to actually get after this so yeah i
know you made this decision okay we're
going to do this then how did it begin
to change things
what'd you start doing um it was pretty
slow to start because
actually of me um i had just
cash flowed my second degree and i was
making
decent money for the first time in a
while and i wanted to spend it
i get that yeah so i i was a little slow
to get on board but i thought i'd be a
good wife and if you wanted to do this
we could put a little bit of money each
month and then
then we bought a hot tub yeah we bought
a hot tub
and then but you paid cash but we paid
cash for the hotel
yeah um if you get a nursing degree you
get a hot tub that's a new day
that's it that's baby step 4.3 why not
okay all right all right
um so i mean from there we had pmi
and once we paid off that pmi i really
got on board and we actually ended up
putting
my entire income towards that from that
point forward
wow yeah cause i was gonna say this is a
tremendous amount here i mean this is
getting with it
i mean was it rice and beans beans and
rice did you go that far
we actually like rice and beans yeah and
we uh canceled
we didn't have tv or just but you had a
hot tub
we sold everything that wasn't nailed
down except for the hot tub
i'm going to tell you this john if i've
got a hot tub i'm gonna be okay with no
tv and rice beans because i can at least
eat my rice and beans
in the hot tub and then y'all had to do
weird married things like
just talk to one another go for walks
and hikes and hang out in the hot tub i
mean
because you weren't just gonna sit there
and scroll mindlessly through some
streaming service right right so my
guess is four years later
after putting in all that sweat equity
and tear equity
your marriage is better too yeah yeah
yeah
we we've definitely come a long way so
talk to other couples what's the key
no matter what their story is what's the
key to getting on board together
and sticking with it
i think you have to have a common goal
yeah and if you have a common goal
and it's worth sacrificing for you can
do it if you believe you can do it
and you have that common goal how old
are you two thirty thirty thirty
so now what you owe nobody anything
and the mail's not gonna stop coming and
people are gonna stop going to hospitals
and so
what's next um we'd like to start
working towards self-employment
uh eventually right now we're just gonna
start saving just save
all right this is what i wanna hear
because this is what i do i try to help
people
achieve their dreams right get promoted
get that dream job
and work like no one else i want to know
what's the dream there working for
yourself
you allow you can you share that you got
you got you got at least a a fuzzy
version of that dream
um owning i think mainly real estate
real estate well now you're set up
that's stacking money okay good that's
fantastic talk to us about your support
system along the way when a couple
decides to do this and
and live really differently and take one
person's entire income and put it
towards debt
that's a little strange who is your
support system really
just each other no one really knew we
were on this journey or
are you really what do you think about
that doc i think these two are gangsters
that's what i think
i it's the quiet ones it's the mail
carrier that's walking around with the
paint off house
right or it's the nurse who smiles a
little bit more because she's got a
little less stress in her life
that's incredible you two yeah
incredible is right
wow unbelievable parents are on board
your friends just kind of laugh and make
fun of you
yeah yeah they would pretty much just
say well why would you want to do that
yeah interesting and so tell us about
a heart i mean the last year has been
rough on nurses
really rough everybody gets off a shift
and they're all going to just
what the closest margarita shop there is
and you say
oh i'm going home exactly sit in my hot
tub and that was the goal have yet
another burrito
what do you say um i mean
i always encourage people to do it and i
think
people don't really understand the value
which is surprising to me
um but i think it's worth it yes
it absolutely you two are free we're
free yes four years in you're free
incredible and now moving steadily
towards
dreaming and making those dreams a
reality so good
so good what a great story all right you
guys ready you've been you've been
warming up i'm ready
you look ready get the hands held there
we go look at that couple
folks it is jacob and heather from
st louis missouri they paid off 155
000 dollars nine hundred fifty five
thousand nine hundred dollars in four
years
and one month making a hundred k
to a hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars
jacob and heather take it away let's
hear your debt free scream
three two one we're debt-free
yes there it is
look at that look at that young couple
that that's the finish line
and and that's what we love about the
debt free speech it's the finish line
yet it's the starting line a whole new
race right whole new race
and they can walk they can run they can
just head off into the woods they do it
whatever they want they hop off the
trail lay under a tree for a couple days
i don't want to blow by this because i
have a tendency to do this i see
somebody
who buys an em makes an impulse purchase
again not everyone impulse buys a house
they did to this debt-free screen
there's digital confetti falling behind
them right all that
in between is four years
of monthly grinding annoyances
frustrations squeezing the last little
bit of lotion out of the tube because we
don't have it in the budget to go get
some more
and you're thinking i make so much money
why don't i have to do this but you keep
going keep going and keep going
so so worth it take a little step in a
little step in a little step
in four years you can look up you're
gonna be there do what you have to do
john so that you can do what you want to
do and this applies to money as well
that's why the baby steps work
so great what a great young couple all
right john and i are to go out and high
five
them congratulate them and then we're
coming right back this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
ramsay show continues i'm kid coleman
joined by dr john taloni as we take your
calls
we are ranch personalities and a part of
the ramsey network
dr john deloney show a fabulous show
new episodes every monday wednesday and
friday on
youtube and you can get them anywhere
you listen to podcasts and the ken
coleman show
syndicated on 70 plus stations around
the country siriusxm
and on youtube monday through friday as
well just search the ken coleman show on
youtube
and wherever podcasts are available and
so
john uh john you focus on
the mental emotional health it's
relationship health i mean just
all across pretty much everything pretty
much everything and i'm focused on
helping people
do what they were created to do simply
put we believe that you were created to
work
now that sounds gross for some of you
when i say created to contribute that
starts to hit a nerve
everybody wants to make a difference
john and it turns out
that some of the stuff you cover and
some of the stuff i cover interconnects
a good bit with toxicity in the
workplace so if you're in a situation
going i need my job dude
i'm walking the baby steps but i don't
know if i can hang on any longer
give us a shot give give us a shout i
would love that and i want to
ask you something ken so was reading
something a few weeks ago and
this author she's brilliant she was
talking about and tell me if you see
this on your show
what we used to as a society we used to
have our small little village
and the small little village gave us our
central values it gave us
the the cultural norms what was cool
what's not cool here's how we talk that
and then it shifted to on a larger scale
our religious communities said here's
here's our
general set of values here's who we talk
how we talk to another whatever
and now we're in this completely
decentralized
universe and we are trying to get
cultural and collective values
from our workplace and so we are all
going to work
and trying to find this sense of purpose
and the sense of value in the sense of
what should i be
dressing and how do we all talk together
and every business has a different
culture and every place and so it's just
decentralizing everything
but it goes back to this idea and i
hadn't thought of it in my head
we are putting a lot into this idea of
work
we're getting a lot of value purpose
meaning this isn't just about earning
the check anymore making sure that
we got food on the table this is about
answering questions like
who am i and what's my role here right
yeah that's new and different it feels
like
no i don't think it is i don't think so
no genesis chapter two makes it pretty
clear that
we were created to work that work is
something that we do
um and so i think that that men and
women throughout history have longed to
make a difference in their world
and i i think purpose comes down to two
areas in our life relationally and
professionally
you you cover relationship i cover the
professional side of things
and what i mean by that is that your
identity and your
value as a human being has nothing to do
with the size of your salary right
or the notoriety attached to your work
but as it relates to significance and
contributing to the world
it matters deeply and so when you spend
you know if there's a reason why
torture the the the the evil nazis that
the torture
was to have prisoners move one pile of
rocks
from one side of the prison camp to the
other just futility huh
yeah that's that's that is not a
physical torture there even though
that's hard work
that was an emotional psychological
psychological
torture there's no meaning in what i'm
doing
and so if you spend your whole life 35
40 years doing a job that
you don't have any passion for you don't
love the work itself
and the work itself doesn't create a
result that you
connect to then that's then that's the
issue so
and what she's saying if she's saying
look we're putting too much
into our title just that
don't under um don't undersell how
important work is don't understand how
important
cultural fit don't understand how
important we're putting a lot in there
well the reason is is because we long to
make a difference
and so the ramsey solutions world view
of work is that
you were created to work you don't
work to live the secular world view of
where just the general world view of
work is that i just
work to get a paycheck to be able to
cover the basics and if i'm fortunate
enough to make more than that
and i can have some toys and make some
additional memories
awesome but it's not a utilitarian
function that's
not the cause of work so is it
this is i never thought of this question
is it my responsibility to bring meaning
to my job or vice versa
for instance if i if someone is
listening to this and they are the
assistant director of the mail room
and the large office complex where they
work
they don't make a huge salary but
without them
this business does not operate yeah so
is it their responsibility to say
to find the meeting and what they're
doing well they need
it's not a responsibility it's a reality
okay
any job everybody that i'm looking at on
our team everybody in here
their job does matter well yeah we could
just run our mouths all day nobody's
gonna
we're nothing without them yeah the
question is does the job matter deeply
to them
and so that's your responsibility so you
need to understand the reality is that a
job
does matter somebody needs to do it if
you're doing it but it's okay that it's
not your
ultimate dream job right now it's where
you are and you're working your way up
maybe you're getting out of debt
whatever your situation but ultimately
what we're teaching is and what i
believe is you need to be in a job that
matters deeply to you all the work
matters
but does it matter deeply to you that's
why we talk about talent passion and
mission coming together so let's put it
this way
if a human being spends their whole work
career just doing something they're good
at
they'll be successful okay they'll
deliver results
and get paid probably get promoted if
they
do something they're good at that's
talent and something they love to do
just the work itself there'll be some
deep satisfaction there
but if they do something they're good at
that's talent and they
ask and they do something they love
that's passion and then
that work that they're doing also
creates results
that fills their heart they go that
matters really deeply to me i like
producing these results there's a
personal connection to these results
that's mission now we're talking about
significance in a person
they begin to see the significance of
their contribution to the world
has nothing to do with success or
satisfaction
or even can can you have a mission that
is
can go from job to job church once you
land there once you know your purpose
and mission
yeah that's what i teach you stay in
your sweet spot the rest of your life
yeah
but you're still moving up yeah and and
that and by the way that that kind of
helps some folks
the dream job's not just one thing
by the way it's not just one career it's
who you're going to be wherever you go
are you using your talent to perform
work that you love
passion to produce results that matter
deeply to you mission
so i could see a person go from and i
get this call the time of the ken
culture we get somebody a teacher that
goes hey i want to i want to move out of
being an elementary teacher and i want
to go into corporate training
let's just break that down so if you're
talented as a teacher
what are the talents you got to have
does that cross over to being a trainer
yes the work you love as a teacher
is that work also something that you
love as a trainer yes that's instruction
they love instruction the research the
instructing the guiding if you will
and then what are the results that
matter to you well if it's teaching and
educating a child or just
mentoring a child or giving a child a
bump yeah but if you're doing that in
the corporate world same thing so
it's like a litmus test of hey as long
as i'm doing this type of work
i know that i'm doing what i was created
to do and therefore
you can do that anywhere anywhere and
it's not about money
you'll make money and you'll have enough
money which is why again teachers are
the third largest group
of net worth millionaires why well
because they're
they they've gone to significance and
satisfaction and success have come along
with it because they had altered their
lifestyle
to fit their mission to fit the mission
you just broke it all down i didn't i
mean look at me learning well you just
interviewed me
so but that's the deal there yeah so
here's the deal let's talk about where
you come into this
we get calls when you come on my show
and some of the calls we could take
today folks if you feel like you're in a
toxic workplace you're going i need my
job to get out of the baby steps i need
the shuffle i need the big shovel
i'll talk big shovel with you but we
could talk about that what's that look
like one of the things we fall into
all the time we get these calls i'm
doing something i love but i can't stand
the place i'm doing it and we say it's
doing the right thing in the wrong place
right you can be in that sweet spot that
we just had fun talking about
and be in a toxic work environment an
abusive environment co-workers may be a
leader who's just a toxic leader
and you can hate going in every single
day you want to talk about confusion
yeah
that's confusion absolutely and there's
no need so let's help you get clear
we'll take those calls and take your
money calls john
then fun hour our producer ben hill our
associate director kelly daniel thank
you
most of all let's thank you america
because you're why we do the show
this is the ramsey
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show
it's where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
your money your work career
your relationships mental emotional
health we're gonna cover it all because
it all
matters in relation to you being who you
are created to be i'm ken coleman host
of the ken
coleman show which is on the ramsay
network and my colleague is dr john
deloney he's also up the dr
john deloney show on the ramsay network
as well and we are here for you this
hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five so question i get a lot on
the ken coleman show uh can i
switch jobs during the baby steps the
answer is yes many times
it's the promotion you need and the
financial
boost so i'm gonna help you with some
big shovel stuff
uh john's gonna hey you know a lot of
times people can't get through the baby
steps because of relational and
emotional issues all kinds of stuff
mental health
um john and i'll team up if you're in a
toxic work environment what to do
and john and i team up on that so i want
you to know that you can ask those
questions and of course your
money questions we are here for you
triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's start it off
this hour in sarasota florida
where jamie joins us jamie you're on the
ramsay show
good afternoon gentlemen how are you
guys today we're having a blast what's
going on with you
wonderful well thank you so much for
everything that you do to help
everyone uh that listens to y'all um so
here's my situation and uh
i'm 39 uh married
i'm uh i have a child and i have a
two-year-old and another one that is due
in july um
so i'm already uh we are already i
should say on baby step
seven wow i and by nature
oh you know we uh obviously we or maybe
said seven we have already you know
money and savings and everything uh
by nature i am i am naturally
stingy i am and i want to become more
generous
so i am wondering what would be some
practical ways to become more generous
so that i can
because in baby step seven is talking
about giving so how can i be
generous and smart at the same time with
the finances that i have man i love that
question jamie i love your heart dude so
why why are you stingy i was
i grew up kind of um always
how do i say this kind of thinking that
i didn't have enough you know and i
never lacked anything but i also never
i always thought you know i'm always
thinking for the future for the future i
kind of like how you guys teach you know
and i'm already thinking about
you know my kids braces and their
college tuition and all that kind of
stuff
um my wife on the other hand she's
extremely generous sometimes i think
she's a little too generous where
people take advantage of her but i want
to be
generous and you know smart at the same
time because
sometimes people take advantage of
generous people
but you know i guess this is the reason
why i'm asking this question
so it sounds like beneath the
because you're clearly smart you're 39
you're a millionaire right you know how
math works
and you're very disciplined and you're
intentionally a millionaire yet but
maybe almost there
okay so it sounds like
beneath the fear
that i think any rational person has is
i'm not gonna have enough that's a
that's a base fear that people have
you mentioned several times this this
idea of
uh being taken advantage of that
somebody's gonna pull it over on you
and where does that come from you've
been taking advantage of before
yes actually um and it's because uh
you know it's funny because it's
actually happened um
uh you know not so much with friends but
um mainly with family
you know where we extend the hand and
um you know we kind of felt maybe in the
past that we
have gotten pooped on and pardoned my
expression
but you know uh though those things have
really kind of marked us
and you know we know that obviously we
know we need to we realize
the importance of setting boundaries but
um
you know but it's the whole idea of
you know giving you know for me it's
something that i want to get to a point
where
it's just so you know so free in that
sense you know and without
obviously being a little too free to get
what i'm saying so here's here's
two two things to think through
um a guy named mitch changed my life
when it came to giving back in college
that's back when we had nothing and um
he had a little bit better job and he
was a little bit better with his money
and one morning some kid came and
knocked on the door
and said you know fill in the blank
we're
selling something or we need some money
for down the street whatever
and mitch said hang on i don't have any
cash but hold on
and i wrote him a check a sizable check
and everyone in the house you know a
bunch of college knuckleheads and was
like oh
he's gonna take that money and go do
this or that
and i'll never forget what mitch said he
said
well that's on him my gift
was he gave me a need and
my gift was fulfilled an obligation i
had in my heart to help
and if somebody wants to take advantage
of me that's going to be between them
and the mirror
not me and then there's a second thing
which is
uh and i've learned this by sitting by
dave there is an intentionality
there is a point when you start enabling
people and so
like you talked about with family and
boundaries right so when you know you're
actually participating in somebody
hurting themselves or hurting other
people
whether it's through supporting
addiction or whether it's fill in the
blank
then you have an obligation to stop so
if i'm in your seat
i'm going to do two things number one
i'm going to sit down with my wife and
be
have a dreaming session who are people
we would love to serve
help what gets us going ken talks about
passion when it comes to work
what are we passionate about serving
other people something in your life
it may be people who get taken advantage
of maybe that's where your passion is
what is that thing you can contribute to
in your community the second thing is is
i would set some relatively aggressive
goals
and then the third thing is this and i'm
making these up off top of my head
brother
is i want to feel and see that
transaction
you know where i get the greatest joy is
when i
am at a restaurant and i see somebody
working like bananas yeah
she is working so hard he's working so
hard and i'm gonna obnoxiously tip
that person i'm gonna blow my budget for
the whole month but i'm gonna tip like
crazy and you just watch him look at
that check
my heart feels good but i know that
their their their
electric bills taken care of that month
because of that one meal that's when
you start seeing the impact in your soul
and in their soul when it comes to
giving
jamie i just got to add i think john
gave you some great things here but but
i
remind remind yourself that you've been
burned with family and you are talking
about setting boundaries and set the
boundaries and know that you're not
going to make that
you're going to make that mistake again
so be free from that you're free you
know what that's like you can do it
again
second thing i would mention is i think
john is right and i was going to say
i would encourage you today or tomorrow
your favorite drive-through place
just pay just start small and build this
muscle because you're scared
and you don't trust people if you want
to get over stingy start small here's
what i want you to do
next drive through say hey person behind
me
how much is their deal i'm gonna take
care of the next time you go to a
restaurant your bill's 50 bucks
tip 100 on top yeah do something small
that you can see and begin to feel
that positive chemical that gets
released
when you go oh that was really fun and
then just kind of
build up and if you don't have to very
big
that's on them you still did the right
thing yeah just start giving
don't think just give don't move more
ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
saved our financial lives christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget friendly option
and the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsay solutions
studios in nashville thrilled to have
you with us i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague
dr john dilloni and we're taking you
through this hour triple eight eight two
five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five uh john you know this
i'm talking to people every day that are
stuck and disengaged in their current
job
and uh ramsey solutions is
a solution for that if you're searching
for a new job uh our get hired live
stream event
brought to you by yours truly tuesday
april the 27th
is for you it's a one night event
tuesday april 27th
8 eastern 7 central you'll learn how to
get clear on what you do best
get qualified for the job you want and
get connected to job opportunities
and this is for people that are starting
out if you're a college kid
if you're trying to upgrade get a bigger
shovel
or you're trying to switch careers the
bottom line is you're trying to
win because that's what getting hired is
you're beating the competition
then this event is for you join me
tuesday april the 27th we're gonna have
a live crowd
about 200 people and we haven't sold out
of that yet so if you're in driving
distance of nashville
or live in the national area and you
want to join us we're gonna do some
special stuff for all you folks
uh go text the word hired
hired to three three seven eight nine
text the word hired to three three seven
eight nine tickets start at just
twenty dollars it's tuesday april the
27th eight eastern seven central get
hired
here from our ramsey solutions world
headquarters let's go to scott who joins
us in las
vegas nevada scott how can we help
hi guys so i have a situation where
i have a 16 year old truck
i paid it off in 2010 and
my dad always told me hey start saving
so when you get you have to buy and
purchase a new
truck or a new car you can pay it out
outright
so i'm at a point right now where my
truck is kind of it's older
it's it's i feel like every year it can
maybe something can happen
but i also owe 100 about 157 000 on my
mortgage
and i'm wondering if i just what's the
best route is it to
maybe possibly put that money towards my
mortgage
and i'm talking about i have about
almost 100 000 in my savings and i have
about
35 i'd say about 35 for emergency
uh and the rest i would you know i was
going to put down a truck
or put down a car eventually but i
wanted to know like what's the best
route to go dude go buy a truck and then
pay the rest down on your house man
you're overthinking this that's it
in the bank you know what that makes you
a unicorn yeah
above and beyond your emergency fund i'm
assuming you have no debt correct
the only bit i have is my house yeah
that's right yeah i understand that but
other than that
so yeah john's right what are you
worried about
well i don't well so i mean my truck is
fine but i feel like it could die at any
minute right like
yeah well scott scott scott if your
truck dies at any moment you got a
hundred grand
sitting in the bank there's absolutely
zero to worry about
okay do you i mean like you wanted to
die
listen i don't know one time my wife
bought a corolla
and we agreed that when the corolla
finally died
i could get a new car did you kill us
early no
you know why because you can't kill a
corolla oh it will be dr
it will be what they drive after the
apocalypse corolla
right somewhere at toyota executive is
writing that down you can't i'm just
telling you
so i got to a point where i'd get in it
every morning and go please don't start
please don't start doing it
is that where you're at scott i mean it
is and
so here's but here's the grand here's my
thing though it's like
i know i want to get eventually i want
to get a tesla cyber truck whenever
those come out
okay that's not going to be like two or
three years so i'm hoping my truck
lasts that long right okay so i'm hoping
on that but that's what i mean is like
do
should i just start and that's my
question should i just start focusing on
putting money towards my
my home payment and then eventually you
know but i wouldn't buy a hundred
thousand dollar truck until my house was
paid off
yeah it's not that it's like sixty
something thousand same same difference
yeah it's a lot of money yeah
so here's the yeah scott buddy
go get something or keep driving this
thing and then put it
let's do this here's what i'd like to
see you do because i think he needs real
direction yeah let's get a hundred
thousand dollars burning a hole in your
pocket seriously
i think and you're frustrated that you
drive kind of a
yeah a beater truck yeah and you got a
hundred thousand dollars in the back
yeah
so so if you're frustrated you've got
the money to go buy it but go buy
something that retains its value
pretty decently and then uh and then if
you if you can afford the tesla thing
down the road
uh then you're gonna get most of your
money back or you're gonna get a good
chunk back you know so if you buy a
uh one of those toys what are those
toyota trucks that just hold their value
for fundraising
tundras you know look dude here's the
deal i'd pay the house off i i would pay
a big chunk down
on the house you got the emergency fund
in place because now you're really
stacking money
um so just walk the baby steps out and
stop thinking about
this but yeah if you want to go buy a
nice car go buy a nice car my goodness
gracious what's the psychology there
john
i think he's got a hundred thousand
dollars burner homeless pocket i think
he doesn't want to spend it though yeah
but you get in that mic
like i've had that where it's kind of an
uppity feeling i drive an old truck and
i think
i got a nice j what am i doing and then
i got to go back to say this truck's
great
it's getting me where i need to be i've
got other goals right my goal
as reverse of his i want to pay my house
off first right so i'm gonna try to
and by the way nothing's wrong with the
truck he said nothing's wrong with the
truck so keep driving the truck just
wants it to die wants it to die what do
i do if it dies
get another one you got a hundred grand
scott
he needs to take a couple deep breaths
you got a breathing regimen for him yeah
it's just he's
tight man it's just that's right
again one of those not too complex
things yeah fantastic he can go get the
wemhop
app and uh learn how to how to breathe
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you're listening to the ramsey show
let's go
north of the border toronto ontario
where vinnie joins us vinnie you're on
the ramsay show
hi how are you guys doing oh we're
having a blast what's up vinny
so yeah my situation is um
i'm basically a recent college graduate
i got 20
000 in debt uh the thing is that i'm
since the pandemic it's been a struggle
to get a job and everything
so you know i've been always trying to
you know
go get into real estate investing it's
been like my dream goal
not my dream goal but like one of the
things i really wanted to do and you
know
the situation that i'm in right now it's
pretty like
no i would say like it's losing my
confidence on a daily basis so i'm just
wondering like what
like i just try to get some sort of
advice out here you know in order for me
to deal with the situation
well i first of all don't attach your
confidence
to and your ability to eventually be a
real estate investor to your current
situation so
your situation vinnie is not your
sentence
this isn't a life sentence you're not a
loser all of a sudden because you're
recently out of college
and you got student loan debt you're
having a hard time get a job you need to
separate those two
number one and then let's get serious
about getting hired if it's two or three
part-time jobs just to get yourself some
momentum right now
the quickest way to get out of a rut is
to get busy is to do
something but sitting around and
commiserating
not that not that that's what you're
doing but just sitting around and
soaking in your frustration
is not the way to move forward get to
work start making some money
follow the baby steps knock the 20 000
out a young guy like you should be able
to do that
sacrifice big time uh john what would
you add to that
vinny do you want to get into real
estate so you can try to short circuit
the deal you're going to borrow some
money grab a house flip it try to earn
that cash and then roll and roll is that
what you're talking about
yeah that like yeah flipping it and all
that stuff yeah that's right yeah but
you gotta do that with cash
yeah here's what's gonna happen you're
gonna go buy three properties you're
gonna leverage yourself to the hilt
the market has lost its freaking mind
and then you're gonna
it's going to roll over on you and
you're going to be bust yeah the market
right now here in toronto is messed up
like it's
uh dude that's always just one mill
listen brother
you're way you're years away from real
estate investing i don't want to be the
the guy that has feelings but you're way
far away right now you need to learn if
you want to go sell houses and get a
real estate license and go work in a
real estate office and learn how the
thing works
listen to what he just said vinnie
that's the deal learn the business but
brother yes
don't go take a bunch of loans out and
try to roll some houses over because
it's going to roll right on top of you
and you're going to be bust
go pay your loans off and scratch and
claw and scratch the clock ken gave you
the best psychological advice
when you get in a rut go do something
yeah
don't just sit there vinny get to work
three part-time jobs
six part-time jobs pay the debt off get
qualified if you want to be in real
estate
use the proximity principle hang on the
line kelly let's give him a copy of my
book start getting around people that
are doing what you want to do
but you better do it the cash way that
means you got to get to work and work
for a while and sell a bunch of houses
save all that money buy a house
cash and begin that process you can get
there
but you're gonna have to work your way
there vinnie come on man
get out of the house get to work
don't move this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john delonia
we're taking you through
this hour of the ramsey show find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one
online retailer of custom window
covering you get free samples free
shipping with the new promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
the promo code ramsey
to get the best deal today's question
there you go
from barbara in virginia john all right
barbara asks my husband and i are debt
free except for a zero percent
car loan of 13 000 should we pay it off
or continue with the 548
a month payment we are retired and have
monthly income of six thousand dollars
our retirement portfolio is one million
dollars
yes paid off yesterday and then be done
the only thing i wish you would have
done
in reading that was do the dr evil 1
million dollars
yeah simple because here's the thing
it's not a you're not playing a math
game you're a millionaire yeah
you're paying you're playing a how many
change
are hitched behind me how many people am
i
subject to and right now you are
willingly
subject to a bank for no financial
reason not because you have to not
because you're stuck not because you
don't have enough money you're just
choosing
every week to be indebted to a bank
and at that point your dollar amount
doesn't make any sense
yeah good stuff there triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
orlando florida where chuck is on the
line chuck
how can we help hey how are you guys
what's going on hey uh
my two ac systems in the house uh
are about 12 years old and they tell me
from about
10 to 15 that they're going to die uh-oh
and
it's going to run about 11 000 to
replace them
and uh i have um i have a good savings
account and i have some stock
so my question is should i pay it all
off
or you know find it consider financing
it
i just don't know don't finance the air
conditioning
just just do not do that how much do you
have in savings
uh about 12 000. okay do you have any
other debt
uh no i'm debt-free except for the
mortgage
okay is that 12 000 include your
emergency fund or is that above that
it does it does okay well that's why we
have stock
how much in stock 46 000
just in single stocks or company stock
uh single stocks
i i invest myself okay
yeah i would actually sell the single
stock and roll that into an emergency
fund of some sort
and then you've got your twelve thousand
dollars to
um pay your air conditioners off and
then you owe nobody any money you're not
going to take a loan out on a
depreciating asset which would be
the air conditioners that the day you
put them in are going to start losing
value
what's your income chuck what do you
bring home uh about 60
a year okay and uh
how much based on your budget right now
how much are you putting away a month or
how much could you if you move the
budget around a little bit how much
could you put away each month towards
the ac replacement fund
um well
i died geez i probably
that's a good question probably four or
five hundred dollars
all right i think you got a couple
options there right we you know range of
solutions we don't
you know we're not saying that you know
being in stocks is evil or wrong we just
don't recommend it because it's a real
roller coaster you can get hurt
uh so i think john gave you a great
option but i just wanted you to
to have in your mind wait a second if i
can put 400 a month away
right now the units are working correct
um yes they are yeah so yes and no
uh actually the inside unit is
got a slow leak on it oh they went ahead
and charged it a couple of days ago
and um so it's on its way out yeah but
let me but let me say this i've been
down this road before i've owned four
houses now
and i've had this happen and here's what
i know about texts they'll come out
there and they'll tell you all the
things wrong with it's like the mechanic
doesn't mean they're evil but that's
just the way they roll
and they go this thing's gonna die
somewhere between
uh year 12 and year or whatever and all
of a sudden what does that do our
emotions go oh my gosh the
clock is ticking well first of all the
tech doesn't know exactly when it's
going to die or he wouldn't be doing
hvac repair all right he'd be in the
prediction business second thing is
even though that hose is leaking you
know there's i like to always ask
okay i get it i get that i'm going to
have to replace this
can i fix that but how much is it going
to cost to fix the hose and keep that
going because
if we could keep that going and extend
the life of this thing with some
uh every once in a while repairs that's
not going to be a big financial hit to
you you've got the emergency fund for
that very
reason and if you begin to save 400
bucks a month
to replacing one of those units well you
can do the math
you know you know how quickly you can
get there and and begin to at least take
care of one i seriously doubt that both
are going to quit the same day
so i just don't want you to act out of
fear is my point
let's act out of facts what are the
facts right now
and let's go that direction and chuck
here here's a an interesting way to
think of it
following ken's line of thinking you can
either start saving money on your own
now
or you can finance this thing and pay
that same money on the back end to
somebody else
yeah i'd much rather own my own destiny
in that in that scenario
yeah right and again john's advice was
really good
you've got stock yeah if i'm you if i if
yeah if i'm in your situation i sell the
stock tomorrow
i it's everything's rocking and rolling
i sell the stock i've got emergency fund
there is no
no drama in my house and then i'd i
probably just go ahead and replace them
yeah call it good yeah if that's if
that's if you're really worried about it
but
you know you're not getting hopefully
not getting killed in the stock market
and you're up right now go ahead and use
that that is your money
and uh that's a really risky thing and
we'd really love for you to consider
uh our investment strategy and reach out
to a smart investor pro
go to ramseysolutions.com find a smart
investor pro or two or three in your
area and interview them and start that
investment strategy that way
but you've got options here you've got
several options but one thing i don't
like is
when when we feel like you know
something's wrong with the car
i mean i can tell you how many times
i've had mechanics go well this is this
is probably going to happen
and i go has it happened no it hasn't
happened it's probably going to happen
okay great
and about what is that going to cost
when it happens
okay just and you just got that money
and
i'm just waiting for what happened yeah
i'm not gonna just drive that car every
day going gee i hope this doesn't happen
today
if it happens we got the aaa we'll get
her over there
we'll fix it i you know just this oh
i've gotta move money now i gotta come
up with money now it's like
do you sometimes the answer is
unequivocally
yes yeah but sometimes it's like no
actually
well before i go buy two air
conditioning systems let me have
somebody else come out and look at them
and get a second opinion before i go
spend 12 grand you know yeah that's a
you know what that's a great point
this is the kind of thing i would really
do i'm glad you brought this up
i'm telling my wife she's on facebook
right i'm not on facebook
going to facebook the whole neighborhood
we live in the neighborhood the
neighborhood's got a page
there's all these next door apps i don't
know all the stuff that i'm i'm not on i
mean you could go hey
anybody got some hvac experience i'm
getting some
i'm getting some different stories here
i got a story that seems pretty gruesome
anybody you just never know some guy
goes yeah i do it i'm your neighbor i'll
come over and take a look at it
why wouldn't you exhaust all options
before you decide to chunk 12 grand
into two new units now the thing going
for this guy is and i get it he's in
orlando it's it's about to get hotter
than the surface of the sun
you need some air conditioning that's
right yeah i i
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah it's
it's that fear thing you talked about
yeah
you know i get the temptation to man
i'll just let's just do it right now
i'll figure out how to pay for it later
and no we're not there let's just be
intentional
yeah yeah i mean goodness gracious i
i grew up in houston so i know what
happens when the air conditioner goes
out is it hotter in houston texas in
july or orlando florida i don't know
it's about the same yeah it's just once
it crosses the 110 mark it just hurts
yeah
kelly's shaking her head i think the
humidity in texas in florida is probably
equal
and that's really what's going on you
know the humidity is unbelievable
but you know john we talked about this
earlier i want people to get this we
have a little bit of fun here with chuck
but you know john's right you know i've
learned this from you
and i talk about this too when you've
got a fear write it out get it out of
your head and let's see if it's
really really truly something i should
be afraid of if i stand close to the
fire
get burned that's a real fear if i try
this career i'm going to be homeless
and live under a bridge that's not or if
it costs 125 bucks to recharge
conditioners for the next three months
yeah i got 90 days to yeah
get some other opinions and ideas and
solutions don't they make some kind of
tape for that kind of stuff it's got to
be some tape at lowe's or home depot
i don't know and you just really
embarrassed yourself there in front of
really america
well i don't know how to fix anything so
i i willingly step into the laughter
there folks
hey i'll tell you what i do know but
we're coming back
to continue to help you this is the
[Music]
ramsey
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsey show
thrilled to have you with us triple
eight eight two five
five two two five i'm ken coleman joined
by dr john dolone and we are talking
about your life
your relationships your money your work
your career path
mental health we're talking about it all
triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to ann arbor
michigan home of my beloved
michigan wolverines andrew joins us
there andrew how can we help
hey john hey ken how you guys doing
today we're having a blast what's up
ah my wife and i are 25 years old and
we're looking to have kids in the next
three to five years um
we don't want to look back and regret
not ever moving out of state
um so i was just kind of looking for
some advice what what do you
what's the regret you fear uh just
staying in the city so we live in a
small town
uh just outside in ann arbor our kind of
fear is that you never go to the
mountains you never uh
never really get to live or experience
living out of state
there's a lot of family members that are
kind of doing that and it's
something that we're just kind of
considering so why don't you just go
move
well it's always come back to finances
and uh the
projection of our future right well why
not travel
have you traveled to some of these
places that you wonder about living in
yes sir yes so
we we would love to go down to tennessee
um
there there's opportunities with my
company there's also opportunities to go
down to the carolinas
um really a lot of regions that we'd
like to live but we
when we have kids we want to be back
here in michigan so the
kind of question i have for you goes
back to our debt
we currently have about 15 000 in
savings that's including our
our emergency fund we have about 98
thousand dollars
in mortgage debt we have 70
000 saved in our retirement and combined
we make a
pre-tax and pre-contribution income of
135 000
um so i guess the the question i have
and we're projected to i'm protected to
pay off the house between
august and october of next year
so i guess my my question goes back to
whether we should
should just wait a year um
how much is your house worth andrew how
much is your house worth
and i know you've got uh 98 000 left so
what would it sell for right now give me
a modest
projection uh i i would think around
between 230 and 250 thousand dollars bro
i don't know what you're worried about
don't let john speak this movie to the
but as long as you don't have an
interruption in income
um you guys you're debt free except your
home you could pay the home off
right now right now if you sell it right
now
you guys have got big time cash and if
you replace your income you said there
are opportunities in the carolinas and
opportunities in tennessee take the
opportunities and you know what
if you wanna if you wanna have kids in
three to five years by the way you have
no control over that zero
okay but let's just say that plays out
for you um
listen to andrew you guys could rent for
two or three years it's not a sin to
rent
you're debt-free if you if you're gonna
come back eventually or
you you might have enough money it
sounds like you might gonna have enough
money to put a nice down payment on
something else and sell that
when the kids come along john you want
to speak to the fear here
it's bigger than that you may have find
some wonderful community in tennessee or
the carolinas in three to five years
never come back and never go back and so
what you're what you're doing is you're
projecting the other side of a coin
while you're
you're projecting what living in on the
tail side is going to be where you live
on the head side
and so you're never going to know until
you go and
here's what you're looking for you're
looking for an iron clad should we or
shouldn't we
that doesn't exist you're just gonna
have to jump or you're gonna have to be
really happy that you didn't jump
or like my family we always said him
we'd love to live outside of texas
it was until we were in our late late
30s before we finally
made the jump and our kids were young
and we never thought we'd do that and we
did
and so you put some artificial
constraints on yourself
and then you're bound in by these
artificial constraints and feel like you
can't move and then
feeling like you can't move makes you
frustrated and your wife frustrated
you're only 25. we should be doing
another
man now's the time to those boundaries
aren't real
right you said it was a financial
problem andrew or a financial issue
there's no financial issues sell that
house
yeah so move move this summer uh let me
just touch up stacey and i had a great
plan
we really did we thought we'd be married
two years and have a baby guess what
seven and a half years infertility yep
four years for us
i mean listen you got no control over
that
so you're you're you just need to do
this
i love the fact of a young couple john
that's in the financial shape they're in
selling their house and going on this
grand adventure because financially this
is not a silly decision
it's not even risky and you get
somewhere and you're 28 and the whole
thing implodes
yeah you got plenty of time to have a
new adventure somewhere else yeah you're
fine you can always go back to
your original small town let's go to
jenny next in colorado springs jenny how
can we help
hey guys thank you guys so much for
taking my call i'm a little nervous
that's okay um we're doing it
okay okay so um
i um i have a business
it's a lasting business in the spring so
i've got two employees
just this week um i signed
another year lease thinking it was just
a normal situation
to go ahead and sign another year lease
for the two suites that i do rent from
from my landlord
last night i found out
the landlord is planning on on selling
the buildings
um and i just signed the lease this week
and found out yesterday my question is
because the real estate is so crazy here
and really hot in the spring
um would it be advantageous
to look into purchasing my own building
um a little bit about my husband and i
my business cleared about a hundred
thousand dollars last year after tax
and we um we owe
182 000 on our house we were hoping to
go ahead
and have our house fully paid for in a
year and a half
uh and we make about 295 total between
my husband and i
um can you afford to buy a building with
cash
well we don't have the for a commercial
property
from my understanding is supposed to
have 25 to 30 percent
down to purchase the the building now my
landlord would love to sell it to me
but she wants to sell it for 750 000
so
jenny jenny jenny you didn't answer his
question but we know the answer
the answer is no you don't have the cash
to buy a building
so if you don't have the cash to buy a
building this is not a good decision for
you
and i don't think you have anything to
worry about just because
your current landlord is selling the
building whoever the new owner is going
to be
they want people renting leasing from
them
i just don't see with the business
you've got going
this is an unnecessary question it's
just you don't even need to think about
buying
anything at all just keep going what
okay really like what if there was a
property that was
less than that that i could occupy the
majority of the space and then have
and not even have a landlord what if a
meteorite
comes directly at us at any moment
or what if my car gets a jet engine put
here's the thing you can what if and you
it's they're all going to be right and
fun and adventurous what ifs
and the chances of them coming through
what i don't want you to do is to go to
colorado springs
take out a giant mortgage on a building
have that entire
market slow down and you're stuck with a
building you can't
fully fund or you can't fully lease or
you're gonna have to
undersell the market you're gonna find
yourself in a mess and then you go from
being a business owner to a business
that's doing really good
to being a landowner right to being a
someone who's in the real estate
business which is a whole other business
so it all sounds good if you can walk in
and pay cash for a building
awesome great do it tomorrow if you
can't
don't bind yourself up into a whole
other adventure and i know you can sit
down and flip over a napkin and make the
math work for you
um i wouldn't do that jenny you and your
husband make
really good money your business is
growing you got a new landlord and it
somehow freaked you out
and then you've created a worse scenario
than actually just continuing to
step forward you're holding a year
leasing your hand
big deal you're good you're fine you got
this
stay the course hey i want to thank our
producer ben hill
our associate producer kelly daniel and
my colleague
dr john deloney but most of all we want
to thank you america this is your show
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermsyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney and we
are a part of the ramsey network and we
are
your host this hour triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five we'll talk about your
money
we'll talk about your emotional and
mental health we'll talk about your job
are you just working in job
you want to make more money you want to
get that shovel bigger so you can get
out of
debt faster you want to actually work on
purpose and enjoy mondays
well that's what we talk about on the
ken coleman show and dr
john dolone helping you on all things
emotional mental health relationships
and we'll talk about your money
as well triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's start it off
with amanda
in colorado springs colorado amanda how
can we help
hey guys oh my goodness thank you so
much for taking my call it's such an
honor to speak with you guys
well the honor is all ours what's going
on today
okay so i want to make this as concise
as possible
um i am um 33 years old
and i have a um really rare
terminal illness um that is in
the essentially what i've been told is
kind of the end stages
um and really at this point i'm kind of
out living the timeline that
doctors have actually given me um which
is amazing
and you know um i'm still believing that
the lord could heal me and um but
realistically i feel like my body
is um failing and um
i have grown up with the dave ramsey
principles i'm out of debt
i got to live my dream job in ministry
and do all the things um but i
am kind of right now unsure
and feel like i'm in kind of uncharted
territory as far as
what to do with finances um
in the like future in the like
present day life
and how to set myself up well not
knowing
um kind of as i call it like terminal
without a timeline
um so i like i said i'm out of debt and
i have
um because of some disability back pay
and some different things i have
um some money and so because of
my illness i wasn't able to like
withstand the cold of colorado winter so
i came down to florida and lived for
what i thought was kind of going to be
the ending like last
six months of my life and i'm still here
um
but i i don't know kind of how to
navigate and um yeah so
i just wanted to kind of get some
perspective on that
well amanda you you're just your telling
of your story is giving us
all uh perspective on our own lives
i don't know that there's a person in
the united states that's listening to
this that didn't just
stop for a second turn the radio up and
so thank you so much for being brave and
for telling us about that
and from the bottom of the heart i'm
heartbroken for you
and your attitude and bravery and way
you are making meaning of this
is an inspiration to me personally to
all of us
is how do you stare what we all know is
coming right how we stare in the face
and also be able to
to recognize and find beauty in every
day and we get to live our dream job and
hey i'm going to go six months and ride
out the last few
months in in florida a place i want to
be and now what do i do so
um thank you so much for sharing your
story with us yeah um
so it sounds like there's two parts to
this number one is the personal
and the second is the financial when you
say you want to know what to do with
your
money explain that a little bit are you
wondering who to leave it to
do you have enough money to get through
treatment tell me what your money
concerns are
kind of all the above um so
i like i said um i
was actually kind of in a um
not really feeling like i was debt-free
and that kind of thing um but then
um once i kind of navigated through um
like disability and different things and
now
um i get a small amount of disability
each month
um i just i guess for me
do you ever have this do you have enough
money to pay your bills
i do yeah i do and i um
are you single do you have anybody that
is a dependent okay
i'm totally single um my mom was a
single mom
and so really she's the only person that
i'm connected to
and um yeah so i guess the thing is i
have enough money
that i could live for a pretty long
amount of time
i think probably longer than i can um
but i guess it's just that fear of
spending it like frivolously
um you know just living you know without
like i've always been a hard worker
and i've always like been
self-sufficient and so just to like
not have a plan and i don't know i guess
that's what i'm asking
is is i feel like the dave ramsey way is
to always have a plan
yeah i don't know so yeah
your plan in your heart and mind you
know how to make a financial plan
um honey you've got enough money to
get you to the end of the ride and so
your goal now is not
like debt free your goal is not everyday
millionaire that's not your goal
your goal is to slide in to
the end with no tread left on your tires
in a safe and responsible way obviously
but your your last months your last year
can be about service can be about
visiting people that you want to visit
can be about
um walking dog it can be about anything
you want it to be
because quite frankly you're a you're
literally an angel that i'm speaking to
right now yeah
and so it's surreal to have outlived the
outlived
right they gave you a short deadline and
that's
you grieved it and then you went to
you you set off into your ship for your
last ride and then
the ride went all the way around and
then you landed back to shore and now
you're kind of yeah
you don't know what to do right and so
well i started a blog
called terminal ain't terrible because
i'm like
just gotta live the rest of my life
there you go thank you
so i to hear what you want to do is
there people you want to go visit
is it serving the least of these you
sound like a person who is so committed
to other people
what are the things that you want to do
you get a rare moment
you get a rare moment that many folks
won't have which is
i've got a clear heart and a clear mind
and i'm financially okay
and but i i know the end is near i know
it's coming
what do you want to do yeah well i've
done a lot of writing
um i um you know i i listened to
ken's radio show and kind of was like
trying to
figure out like a job with like writing
and creating a blog and monetizing it
but
i think like perspective-wise that was a
little bit like
time-wise not gonna work um amanda
here's what i would tell you
number one we're gonna be praying for
you as john said you inspired us listen
you need to decide you want to leave
some money for a mom if you don't have a
will get a will
kelly will connect you if you need that
but i would decide
how you're going to live and it's about
relationships from here on
from here on out that's jobs it's all
relationships and i love that you're
writing but it really is about
what you want to do this is you leaving
your mark
we're honored that you called us that
you shared this story
amanda make it count this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions worldwide headquarters
in nashville
so excited that you've joined us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney and we're taking your
calls this hour on your life your money
your relationships your mental emotional
health your work
that advancing making more money
whatever we're taking
that call for you triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five
two two five when it comes to life
i don't know if there's a bigger life
change than buying a home or maybe
getting married having a baby
and when that change comes comes at you
there's a lot coming you're thinking
about a lot
and you need to make sure that you're
thinking about the right insurance
coverage
those big changes are overwhelming but
it would be even more overwhelming if
you find yourself in a situation where
you and your family
are in a hole because you weren't
covered if not having the time or energy
is what's keeping you from getting the
right
insurance coverage use one of our
endorsed local provider or elp
insurance agents to help elps are
independent agents that shop a variety
of insurance options to find you the
best
option and then they explain all the
technical lingo so you know exactly what
you're getting
for free all you have to do is text the
word
insurance to 33789 text the word
insurance to 33789 to get connected
with an elp and get the coverage that
you need text the word insurance
to 33789
let's go to the city of angels los
angeles california nancy joins us on the
line there nancy how can we help
hi it's an honor you guys to speak to
you both well he honors our all
ours how can we help well i'm calling
because
i'm in a bit of a conundrum i'm 46 years
old i'm a single mom
and i am about to start baby step 3b
but i am concerned because um
i don't have very much saved for
retirement
i do have a pension but
my dream is to someday own a home
and while i'm you know cash flowing my
daughter's college as well
i'm just kind of wondering what should i
do should i begin
to save for retirement and just kind of
um not be as intense in terms of saving
for the down payment i know it's going
to slow me down
or should i just focus my efforts in
saving for the down payment
and make sure that when i am ready to
purchase that home that i can pay it off
before i retire why are you cash flowing
your daughter's college
i'm sorry um why are you cash flowing
your daughter's college
um because i don't want her to you know
be in the same situation that i was in i
mean
i had a lot of student loans and
i just wanted to make sure that she's
you know set up
and that when she graduates that she
doesn't have
so i'll let ken talk through the money
part but i've seen this with parents
over the years working in colleges
and they end up making a trade
unintentionally and the trade is
i don't want my students to have student
loan debt because i remember the pain of
that
and so instead of investing in their
retirement
they put that money into the college
fund and what that
what that means is instead of the kid
having student loans to pay off
or having to figure out another college
option that may be cheaper less
prestigious et cetera
they assure that mom's gonna have to
move in and that kid's gonna have to pay
for mom and old age
so it there's a hundred percent chance
that you're gonna have to retire there's
a hundred percent chance you're gonna
get old
and there is a million options
other than having to cash flow your kids
college
and it ends up just being a reverse
burden it's going to be a different one
but it's still going to exist there if
that makes sense
and so i'll pass it on again i i just
want to put that out there because i see
i hear and see parents do that all the
time
your priority right now has got to be
making sure you've got a home
making sure you've got retirement and
then
working to figure out a solution for
your daughter in college yeah nancy
you're a great mom
first of all i mean yes you're just got
a huge heart and i understand
why you're doing what you're doing but
john's absolutely right this is not your
burden
and if you walk the baby steps out okay
and you know the baby steps
so you're in the 3b which is kind of
developed over time right
the baby step 4 is 15 toward retirement
and
then we move towards the college and all
that stuff and so you're just in a
situation where you're behind the eight
ball there and i think you feel that
burden and you shouldn't feel the burden
i think i think you and your daughter
are going to figure something out
what i want to know is is what's your
income
about 105 a year 105. do you have room
for advancement there or do you feel
like you're i mean
tell me what your prospects are as you
see them
um i do love my job and i'm very happy
doing what i'm doing
um there is over time you know the
opportunity for my income to
to increase um how much are you putting
towards your daughter what's your
monthly spend on the daughter's
education
not very much she um she understood from
the very beginning
that she had to stay here in california
and she's doing stage college in roughly
a year
um i pay about 2 000.
four thousand dollars a year for for her
tuition and books
because her father does help okay so
you're putting forth
okay that's good that's really good i'm
glad to hear that that that is good
um but again i think what john said is
right i mean what we want to see you do
is
is really begin to get on your on your
uh
your retirement because she can earn
four thousand dollars she can earn four
thousand dollars i'd like to see that
four thousand dollars going towards
you know again if you want to save for
the house that's fine but you need to be
on
if you really want about how long you've
been renting by the way i'm curious
since uh since forever i didn't really
discover dave ramsey until about three
years ago yeah hold on a second
i don't want you to feel guilt over that
i hear tremendous
guilt and shame over that that's not
that's not a bad thing
nancy i want to set you free from that
the reason i asked is it's not a sin to
rent
when financially you're not in a
position to buy a home and you're not
and i love that you're going after baby
step 3b
but i also want you to to be looking at
your retirement portfolio and that was
my next question
so i don't we got to keep moving here
but don't feel guilt over that yeah i i
rent i've rented for years and years i
just recently bought so it's all good
yeah you're not wasting money nancy now
where are you at retirement to this
moment what do you what do you have save
for retirement
um well like i said i do have a pension
um
and as soon as i mean i didn't really
know very much about investing
um i have about i don't know i would say
about 30k
in annuities um and i stopped that
completely once i decided to
you know follow the the steps so i
haven't really
invested a whole lot um and that's why i
think i'm feeling this
sense of of panic and i keep telling
myself well there is a pension but i
know
that well hey don't be panicked uh i
thought you told me you were 46 years
young did i remember that correctly
that is correct come on let's hear it
nancy for 1974. i'm 46 as well
so nancy i don't think i'm i don't think
i'm old so
i i promise you i don't think you're old
so number one no more panic
no more guilt and shame over rent can i
get an amen doc
yeah and no more panic here's and listen
listen listen no more guilt and shame
over parenting
yeah more guilt and shame over the
relationship that didn't work out you
got this
no more of it so nancy here real quick
we got to run through some things have
you met with one of our smart vester
pros
i'm not yet you need to go to
ramseysolutions.com as soon as this call
is over
and as dave has taught us and we say the
same thing i want you to interview three
four five until you get one that feels
like they definitely have the heart of
the teacher and you've got a connection
with them i want you to sit down and let
them see your stuff and say
i just called the ramsey show and here's
where i am now i've got a little bit of
panic and i know i need a plan and an
absent of a plan
the brain goes wild and then we we get
panicky so i want you to get with a good
smart rester pro and begin to map this
thing out
the four thousand dollars we need to
bring that back in
and we need to either put that towards
baby step 3b uh let's look at your
current 401k whatever you've got going
on at work
let's let's work towards that but but i
want you to
sit down and figure out what a real
retirement plan looks like and i think
you're gonna go okay
i do have time i can be really gazelle
intense now at this level too
and i can catch up it's not too late and
there is an entire culture built around
making moms especially single moms
feel like you are a perpetual screw-up
you've done everything wrong and you'll
continue to and that is a lie
you're a great mom you're in a position
now you're not too late to turn it
around
you have turned it around and now it's
getting the right people in your corner
to get down this new path
you're on it nancy you're rocking and
rolling i'm so proud of you yep
take your time take a deep breath the
house will be there
when you're ready for it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from ramsey
solutions headquarters in nashville
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney so grateful that you
have joined us
it is your show america and therefore
we have a phone number for you to jump
in triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's
go to joe who joins us in harrisburg
pennsylvania joe
you're on the ramsay show hey hey ken
hey dr john how you guys doing
we are having a blast what's it all
about for you today
okay so i'm 23 um i just graduated
college in may
and i'm a i'm actually a personal
finance teacher it uses dave's high
school curriculum
oh great thank you my question is i have
twelve thousand
five hundred dollars left on my student
loans and i do a monthly budget
um as i should as a personal finance
teacher i get
um yes but i i have it planned out that
i'll be debt free
um by the end of summer so end of august
that's how i haven't budged out because
i'm still living at home with my parents
um so i'm able to save a lot of money
like that i've already paid off like
um about twenty thousand dollars good
for you my question is though since they
are in
deferment until september and there's
all this talk about you know
the possibility of some uh of the death
being forgiven like i'm not planning on
that
but would it be wrong of me to put my
money
in the savings account that i've
budgeted every month until september
in case it happens then once september
hits and it doesn't happen i just pay
that twelve thousand five hundred
dollars
because my next step would be buying a
house and i
just would be an awful feeling in my
stomach if i could have had ten thousand
gone i could put that
towards the house yeah i you know that's
a very logical question john
and joe i'm going to tell you something
um there was a point in my life where it
was a possibility that i was going to be
able to dunk a basketball at least that
was
really that was the thought no no no it
never was a possibility
that i'm making my point here and i
don't think it's a possibility that the
government's gonna pay your loans off
i just don't see it happening i think
it's i think it's one in a million
chance it happens
uh but to answer your question answer
your question straightforward
it's not wrong you know but that's not
what we're going to recommend
i don't think it's morally wrong it just
puts yourself in a temptation
to if you put that aside and you stop
the plan
a plan that you're going to execute in
just a few months at the end of the
summer
it creates all levels of temptation and
my colleague is far
far more qualified to talk about the
psychological there and so that's why
we're never going to recommend that you
do that but it's not morally wrong
joe here's here's my heart on it you're
a smart guy
is that correct i i
i think so that's like the impossible
question i know i set you up here
so you are a smart guy you would be a
finance he's like uh
no josh [ __ ] hey so
at the end of the day where i struggle
with this
as a guy who me and my wife have what
seven degrees between us we had
six figures of student loans and then i
started con
using student loans to consolidate cars
and credit i went bananas with student
loans
all right yeah here's the thing
nobody tricked me every i didn't i
didn't
i didn't count the cost i didn't sit
there and add them up every semester and
see what i
you know how deep the hole was but i
didn't know to do that
right so at the end it was i kind of do
to it
but here's the thing i signed my name to
a piece of paper and that paper said hey
if you'll help me get through college
i'll pay you back
and so for me this is an integrity
question
and you are somebody who has a a
blessing and that your parents and you
get along you're allowed to stay there
and save up this money and there's
something in my
soul that wouldn't sleep right knowing
that i waited on the government to bail
me out of the choice that i made
an integrity decision that i signed a
piece of paper saying i'll pay you back
because you helped me get through school
and so you have the ability
to work really hard and be debt-free on
your own two feet
in a few months and there's a part of me
that
as a guy who's walked alongside students
for so many years what i'm going to tell
you is
you're going to have your head held high
brother and
if if you pay it all off in august in
september they say hey we're waving 10
grand
you're going to go you're going to turn
around and what you're going to do
is like most americans should you're
going to get indignant you're going to
say wait a minute
i just worked my butt off to complete
the agreement that i
signed and you're just going to wipe and
then you're going to say well
so it is i stood up on my own two feet
and i paid it off you can join the
ken coleman grumpy old man club because
i paid mine off and my wife paid hers
off
married yeah and it's like i don't think
they should defer that i don't think
they should uh
get pay these things off i don't like it
i don't think it's right all right then
if you agree then keep walking it
forward
i just didn't want the fomo you know hey
you know what listen you're gonna have
fomo whether you're
just learn now that fomo's a choice
right it's a choice that's a great call
and you know what else joe you're
rocking it man
yeah pay these things off you can still
live with mom and dad a little longer
and save up for that house payment or
whatever take your time
i got to tell you this john it's very
normal but now being 46
having gone through the early 20s i got
married at 23.
okay yeah i get it
but you don't have to buy a house no
to prove that you're a success or that
you aren't a loser or whatever the
narrative
is joe doesn't have to be in a hurry to
buy a house not that it's man if you
if you get an apartment at 23 you're
just pouring your money down the drain
you're just flushing it down the toilet
no you're not no you're not you learn
how to grow up you're saving some money
outside of mom and dad's house
right and we're not talking about you
joe talking about anybody who's 23
man and you have the opportunity to live
at home it's a it's a healthy situation
you pay those loans off really fast
and then go live in an apartment for a
few years yeah slow down
save your money let this market cool off
have cash in your hand and go put down
20 30 40 on a house when people need to
get out you're gonna get a great deal on
a house
yeah just everybody exhale for a second
especially you 22 23 24 year olds
yeah i mean renting is not a sin we got
to say that
over and over and over let's go to
houston texas
where jessica joins us jessica you're on
the ramsay show
hi how are you we're having a blast
jessica what's going on
so my husband and i have completed uh
baby steps one through three good
way to go jessica thank you thank you
we're very proud of it
um and we are currently
uh we currently just finished baby step
three
but we found it to be very difficult
because
we recently just welcomed um our first
baby in december
yes yes yes um and we were told that we
had to pay a certain amount
for us to have our baby at the hospital
so we paid that it was in the budget we
paid it
um but the problem is is that we keep
receiving medical bills
from um myself and my son
stay at the hospital so we found with
step three
it was a constant we were saving for
three to six months and then stopping
and then saving and then stopping
to pay off the medical bills um and now
that we're transitioning
to step four um we're not sure how to
still treat the medical bills if we
should still treat it like it's a
debt because we're finding that we're
constantly starting and stopping because
we just received these random medical
bills
from when from the birth of our son so i
am in a similar situation not with a
baby
but i went i had to go to the er over
the christmas holidays
and i went in there and in the er they
had this you know it was
like a robot on an ipad and they brought
them out and they said here's what the
cost is going to be and i have
an hsa so i paid the hsa
and the the amount they wanted i didn't
have that much in my hsa account
and so they said well we'll just move
the what you owe us down
i said i don't want to cash pay i don't
want to give you any insurance just want
to pay cash and get out of here
so they moved it down and i have this
recorded i said
you're telling me this is the final bill
forever this is it they're like yes your
cash pay you're gonna be able to walk
out of here
and we're gonna all high five i said it
again and again and again
and there's this thing saying this call
is being recorded and it's flashing up
there right
and then just the other day i got
another bill so what'd you do
i'm gonna call the hospital and say
you're gonna check your records
i'm not gonna pay anymore we agreed on
this i gave you this cash
and what i think i don't always think
it's the hospital's fault i think
different departments build differently
but there's a central department that
says here's the cause
they need to get their house in order so
what i would do is fight this and give
them a call say here's what we agreed on
i'm not paying this anymore and if you
send me the collections i'm gonna go get
a great attorney
in houston okay don't let him take
advantage of you
you paid your bills you'd be done with
it go
fight this jessica all right don't move
more ramsay show right after the break
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john dolone
and we're taking your calls about your
life
your money your relationships
your work triple eight eight two five
five
two two five our scripture of the day
hebrews 10
23 and 24 let us hold unswervingly
to the hope we profess for he who
promised is
faithful and let us consider how we may
spur one another
on toward love and good deeds our quote
of the day from anne frank
no one has ever become poor
by giving that's powerful stuff
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to boise idaho where
roberto joins us roberto you're on the
ramsay show
hey guys thank you for having me you bet
what's going on
hey so just a question i'm 24 years old
i'm a new registered nurse i just
graduated in december congratulations
man thank you i appreciate
that um the only debt that i have is
something that i did
pretty dumb about a month ago i
purchased a new truck
um so it's about 24 000 in debt okay
now i wanna go back to grad school in
like two to three years
to be a anesthesiologist and the average
cost
of the entire three year program is
about a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars depending on what school you go
to
so i've been having some like buyers
regret and i wanted to
get someone's opinion like do i sell the
truck and focus on saving for school
or do i just pay off the truck first and
then go from there i didn't know if i
if i sold the truck if i needed to treat
the future debt like how i would in baby
step two and just focus on
you know saving up all that money for
school how much is the truck worth
so the truck is worth i'd say
19 000. the extra like four or five
grand was for like the maintenance and
the warranty and stuff how much do you
make right now
so i make uh every month
i make i would say 1700 uh i'm sorry
man you're nursing at the wrong place
yeah 3 500
a month and how old are you i'm 24. okay
yeah i mean get rid of the truck you
know but you gotta have something
you gotta have something to uh to drive
i'm guessing or are you in a situation
where you could
use public transportation to get to your
job i have no idea what boise idaho is
looking like and where you're at
what are your transportation needs yeah
i'd probably have to buy a car i have
about like four
four thousand five thousand dollars
saved up yeah let me tell you something
i want you this is what i want you to do
tonight before you go to bed i want you
to go on autotrader.com or find other
cars.com i don't care i'm not endorsing
any website i'm just telling you go go
to one of those websites
and just and just put in your budget and
see what's out there i think it's going
to blow your mind of how much quality
something that will get you a and b
and it doesn't look like you know rats
have been living in it
um and i think that's what you do and
you get this debt out of your life
and now you're back to square one when
you're debt-free
and then i'd get after i'd get after it
i'd work i'd take as much overtime i
don't know what the options are for you
as a nurse there but
you know you want to save up and cash
flow your way through this the other
thing i want to challenge you on
is you said on average the schooling you
want to do is 130
000. what's the low end on that
like 100 i'd go 100. and
let me tell you why nobody
i mean nobody roberto cares where you
went to school
take the cheapest option if it's viable
take the cheapest option don't go don't
go average
go the lowest cost possible and i would
delay it
i'd work my tail off and i'd delay it
until i have it all in the bank
because it's just not going to be worth
it i promise you
and roberto i want you to hear what
you're saying the next three years
right you're 24 years old you're playing
a 30 year old game
as a 24 year old you're gonna work every
weekend
you're gonna work every night you're
gonna stack that money and stack it and
stack it and stack it
and then you're gonna go pay cash and
you along the way
you're gonna develop a reputation as a
great nurse
i was gonna say killer nurse and that
had a bad connotation yeah you're gonna
be
recognized as a great nurse you're going
to get some
extraordinary experiences because
there's difference of working the night
shift as the morning shift
you know that and then you're going to
be ready to
exhale and go to a graduate program get
your feet underneath you you're going to
pay cash and you're going to come out as
a 28 29 year old
making a jillion dollars as a nurse
anesthesiologist
and you're going to have no debt and
then it's going to be game on brother
and listen don't just hear what john
said i want you to feel the truth behind
what john said
because when you do that he just gave
you a beautiful fast forward into the
future
and when you come out that way there's
going to be other people in that
anesthesia program that are just crushed
by debt
and every nickel they're making is going
just to keep their nose above water i
want you to
feel that future i want you to feel the
difference
if you can if you can place yourself in
where your
other fellow students will be versus
where john placed you
that will keep you from being tempted
i'm telling you
the degree is there the anesthesiology
jobs are there the money are there but
please
please please do it the right way here's
a picture what that looks like
as i was a dean of students of a law
school and then i went back to get a
second
degree i drove an old corolla like an 01
or a 2000 corolla because i was going to
put my money over here versus over there
didn't make me any better than anybody
else
anything like that and man my buddies
gave me a hard time my
my friends and colleagues and they
should have right i looked ridiculous
but it was an internal decision i want
this more than this right
and so i want him to know man you can
keep pulling into that same hospital
parking lot over the next two three four
years
in a used honda or a used whatever
you're not gonna impress anybody that's
not your goal right now your goal is a
debt
free walking across that graduation
stage as an anesthesiologist a nurse
anesthesiologist
owing nobody anything and then then
brother
the world is yours right yeah now you're
talking about stacking money
and anywhere in the country right you
could go anywhere with that degree
yeah you know i want i want to stay here
because i think this is such a it's such
a temptation and it's such a
it's a mental mountain for people to get
over an emotional mountain to get over
let's play this out so if if somebody
does it the way
everybody else if roberto does it the
way everybody else does it he's not
going to he's already told us that
you come out and you're so burdened by
debt
and you realize that okay i got the
degree i got the job i'm making good
money but i'm not
tasting the fruits of that i'm not
seeing the fruit of that i i know i'm
making it
but it's disappearing and then all of a
sudden the
resentment and frustration begin to
build
and it becomes toxic and then they call
the ken coleman show john they go
i'm burned out i don't i don't i don't i
gotta
i gotta find a new career and i go what
and we dive into it we find out no you
don't you're just miserable you're
resenting
yourself you're resenting the job
because you're having to work crazy
hours
and you don't find yourself getting
ahead and you go did i make the wrong
decision
you didn't make the wrong decision on
the work is what i find most of the time
you made the system decision financially
and then you just never get hit
versus holding off here and he comes out
and goes man i'm doing the work i love
i'm in my sweet spot but boy oh boy i'm
also
like in high school when we were getting
in shape we had to pull tires
yeah right you sprint you're pulling
that tire behind you and man you sure
can run fast when
you're in a game when you don't have a
tire behind you right not the truth and
that's debt right
you can run anywhere you want to yeah
it's awesome so you got to be careful
it's such a great exercise john to get
out there in front of it and go and wait
a second what's the desired future
if i don't do the debt what's the future
look like
if i am straddled you know or saddled
rather with debt you know and
because well here's his life he's got a
24 000 truck
he's gonna go to work in a high stress
high yes
uh secondary traumatic stress gig is
hard
his buddies are going to want to get off
shift and go hang out go eat go hang out
go eat
he's going to meet somebody they're
going to bring dead into that
relationship too
and then they're going to need to buy a
house and then he's going to want to go
to grad school
and then suddenly you're going to look
up and like you mentioned you're going
to be living life underwater yeah
as opposed to just biting down on your
mouthpiece for a couple of years going
in there swinging
and you turn around 26 27 years old yeah
man you set your you set your entire
legacy up
and it's so frustrating ken and it's so
hard i know here's here's what i found
just about anybody says i'm willing to
do what it takes you betcha but then you
say are you willing to wait as long as
it takes
whoa that's good everybody's willing to
do it it takes very few are willing to
wait
as long as it takes that's the
difference patience
is the magic gotta have it hey i want to
thank my colleague
dr john delaney always fun to be with
you pal want to thank our producer ben
hill i want to thank kelly daniel our
associate producer and i want to thank
you america
thank you for joining us this is your
show this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you